what is Iran's ultimate motive from the
seeder the river they want to control
the whole Middle East so what do you
think about our move to pull the troops
in 2012 good move or bad move
terrible move tell me why you have to
know when al-qaeda member run away in
Iraq they end up going where some of
them end up coming to this country we
make this decision here's what could
potentially happen that terrified them
and that's why they sent soleimani an
order for revolution happen you know
what's gonna happen with students it's
gonna cost a lot of lives if you think
you're gonna get it peacefully because
they've been protesting peacefully it's
not gonna happen nothing comes for free
where does the ayatollahs go if they
leave Iran he has nowhere to go they are
ready to kill every single citizen they
love their ideology more than they love
their own people there has to be
sanctions there has to be precious
shooting people and the head if they
ever come after your family or no I
never went home you talk about a coup or
revolutional regime collapse that's what
you're talking about
yeah is that possible for that to happen
we won't have peace and the Ayatollah
goes away
did you ever think you will make good I
feel I'm suppose I could take sweet
victory I know this slice meant for me
yeah yeah why would you bet on Goliath
well we got fat a V value Taemin giving
values contagious this world of
entrepreneurs we can evaluate this
hottie run homie look what I become I'm
the unborn
[Music]
so today I have a special guest with me
since all the issues and controversies
taking place between u.s. and Iran and
the Middle East I figured it made sense
to get somebody that actually lived in
Iraq and experienced it so today's guest
is Hamid II Jassim who wrote the book
terrorist whisper which you'll find out
here in a minute why this is when
Saddam's regime fell Iraqi military
restarted a new army new military he was
the 19th soldier of that military and he
became the youngest sergeant major at 19
years old and today we're gonna find out
about the conditions of the Middle East
from somebody who was in it I'm only
thank you so much for coming out thank
you very much for having me
so before we go into your story I mean a
lot of the things you're seeing right
now with the news you're seeing that Sam
soleimani you're seeing Iran you're
seeing World War 3 you've seen all this
stuff how are you processing all this
information for somebody that's been
there before it's um it's kind of
surprising you know especially the
killing of Kozma soleimani you know but
I think many people don't realize that
what Qasem Soleimani role is in that war
in Iraq I mean my days goes back all the
way down back to 2006 2005 when sulemani
was just establishing his little
militias in Iraq and was going around
Iraq communicating with al-qaeda and
anybody that was fighting against the
United States during that period so it's
kind of surprising actually to see
finally that we put an end to silly
monies efforts in the Middle East
because so the money wasn't just really
any Iranian general he was basically the
smartest person in the Iranian regime
and silly money had figured out the keys
to the Iraqi government which is
something that the American government
did not know how to contain or control
because selling money have controlled
the Iraqi government with a fist for the
last 15 years probably and have you have
had a chance to see him have you ever
been around him I have witnessed the
movement of some money about 20 feet
when I was working as an undercover
intelligent asset for the US
intelligence he started moved
comfortably in Iraq as much as the US
troops started taking their hands away
from Iraq as you know the rockie
government was completely majority of it
was appointed by Iran and the person
that would choose these individuals or
LED them or put them through the process
to become an asserting position was
selling money himself majority to people
in Iraq that were put into power were
chosen by those in Iran absolutely
so my money would actually be the one to
to select them and they would never get
the position of salim improve so the
media is painting us to two different
soleimani i want to know from you having
been there yourself one side is you know
iran loved them 82 percent approval
rating all this stuff they keep hearing
about you know people mourn thousands of
people showed up to his funeral
that's one side right the other side is
a brilliant strategist killing iranians
killing iraqis killing US soldiers you
know vicious terrorist kurds doesn't
matter what it is anybody that's in his
way he's going through them how do you
view muir celfon experience I think he's
been the perfect tool for the Ayatollah
since the 80s in putting down protests
and taking care of all the enemies of
the Ayatollah or the enemies in Iraq or
Syria or any other countries he you can
never underestimate the intelligence of
Soleimani silly money has a controlled
Iraq he called all the shots and I think
that silly money was a competitor for us
as a US government as US military US
intelligence he was one of our main
competitors until about 2012 when we
pulled the troops he became actually the
main person to dominate Iraq so what do
you think about our move to pull the
troops in 2012 good move or a bad move a
terrible move tell me why a terrible
move because once we pull the troops out
of Iraq
it gave Iran the full power to actually
finally have their control of Iraq and
the Iraqi government itself you have an
example the person that died was silly
money Abba mania Mohandas was actually
not allowed to be in the Iraqi
government at all until about 2012 only
pull the troops so if we wouldn't have
let you say we don't it's 2012 we don't
pull the troops we stay there what
changes what would have been different
today
none of the key figures in Iraqi
government none of the faces that
one towards Fame we would have been as
active as they we're in the last few
years I think that pulling the troops
that have gave them an opportunity to be
part of the Iraqi government most of
them were wanted by the US government
some of them were people that fought
against the US military and they would
not have found the chance to be in a
position like that they used to compete
for that power once we pulled the troops
it became an open land for them and they
took control completely of the Iraqi
government perhaps because they're the
only armed group within the Iraqi
government and they started controlling
the Iraqi government one branch after
the other including the army itself now
2012 was Barack Obama as the US
president versus now we have Trump
you're in it there's a big difference
between me saying here's what's going on
the streets of you know Baltimore or
Chicago or you know Iran Tehran whatever
it is versus you're actually in there
yourself seeing the decisions being made
from the top of the president what is
the biggest difference between the way
decisions were made with Barack Obama
versus the way the decisions being made
right now with Trump I think the media
would portray them differently to the
American people but what I see
differently is that President Obama made
a huge mistake by pulling the troops the
way they did the truth should never have
been pulled the way they the way they
where they if we planned a pullout for
the troops we should have a planned it
in stages and we should have not left
the Iraqis alone it's almost like
handing you a house without a roof and
that's what really happened in Iraq we
had so many projects so many things that
the US military and the Iraqi military
and the Iraqi government were working on
together and all of a sudden we just
disappeared and decided to leave and
people like hallouwe murray al Mohandas
had a great opportunity he'll come back
but you know sometimes voters will get
out there and they'll say what a noble
thing to do to pull troops out we got to
get out of there let them figure it out
because there's two sides to it right
one side is like why are we getting
involved with everybody's problems why
should we get involved with everybody's
prompts and then there's another side
saying we got to get them all because
there's business dealings Human Rights
etc etc what are your thoughts on both
arguments being made
I think Iraq fell a victim because of
the condition here between a Republican
and Democrats and I think none of them
have really looked at the big picture to
realize that pulling out the troops
would have cost more damage and you have
an example of what happened in Iraq
after the troops pulled out Isis had the
biggest comeback perhaps most of the
Isis fighters that you faced in Iraq
escaped out of prison after the troops
pulled out of Iraq 45 days exactly up to
the troops pulled out of Iraq over 600
al-qaeda member scaped out of the Abu
Ghraib prison so this was a comeback for
everybody not just for OMA honda salami
and and soleimani to have even stronger
grip in iraq it was a comeback for the
for for Isis and the extremists as well
so it left Iraq open and Iraq it became
an easy place for anybody to do whatever
they want do you think Barack Obama and
his administration when they're making a
decision like that you don't shoot like
we would assume they have all the Intel
to know that if we make this decision
here's what could potentially happen do
you think they know that and then they
did it what do you think they didn't
know that and then they made the
decision so all depends on the advisors
that have you know I'm expecting as a
president of the United States you
should have advisors that evaluate the
situation away from the political views
and that's the problem we've been having
in America we should not be evaluating
things based on political views and I
think that they knew the consequences
but they were looking to convince the
American people and have a win here in
the US by pulling the troops but in Iraq
we didn't when many lives were taken
many as 80 children were taken as sex
slaves
it caused a disaster Mosul fell under
the hands of of Isis and that's not only
to blame it on under Obama inspiration
also to blame it on the key figures that
took over after the pullout of the
troops I mean al-maliki had back then
the prime minister of Iraqi he had a
part through it all the corruption that
was happening was also part of what's
happening but I believe once the troops
pulled out corruption became its full
capacity in Iraq it went to a hundred
percent full capacity absolutely worse
than Saddam oh absolutely
okay absolutely I mean if you I mean if
you think about Saddam before Saddam was
to its
what that any of Saddam Minister was
would would dare to steal something
during Saddam nobody but all the sudden
and you'll have a country with so many
Saddam's and every single one of them is
still in the country in his own way so
the country just went to a chaos
everybody was stealing the army
the Ministry of oil everybody was
stealing whatever they are and you know
things were getting divided based on the
religious background Iraqi government it
was not who is qualified in the raca
government it was which political party
which is llama group that you represent
so you take this ministry and you steal
a hell out of it
that's how that's always so things are
you saying things were smoother in Iraq
when Saddam was in there I wouldn't say
like you know things were as smoother
Saddam was the only bad guy look at it
this way and then all of a sudden you
had all the bad guys that competed
against Saddam to take power from Saddam
because the people who actually came and
took part of the Iraqi government of
Saddam after Saddam had fell out it was
the people that didn't like Saddam who
were living in Iran under the protection
of the Ayatollah and mostly were members
of the battacor and they're not any
better they're just as bad as Saddam
Hussein how worse can things get right
now the way it's going I think the way
it's been going before the killing of
Qasem Soleimani we expected them to kill
every single protester in Iraq and they
would not leave that place and that's
what I always said they would kill every
single Iraqi and they're ready to do
that before they leave power
even though 20 Soleimani pre-sold money
selling money but killing of the Qasem
Soleimani has really left Iran a shock
right now the relationships that
Soleimani held in Iraq him and our
Mohandas were that basically the the two
key figures that held the whole entire
Iraqi government
so now Iran has to come back and
establish all these so Iraq right now is
under a golden opportunity to actually
free itself from the Iranian influence
you think they'll do it I mean if you
have millions of people protesting and
they've been getting shot in the head
you know hundreds of Iraqis as you know
has been getting killed protesting
peacefully for for their country against
the Ayatollah and flow
Iraq and they're still out there
protesting as we speak I think this is a
generation that is very different they
did not live into the Saddam regime is
not afraid of anything they are facing
it the way they are and I think that
these are the future for us but I don't
think they will leave peacefully
I don't think they want you don't think
they're gonna leave peacefully now okay
so how much of this how much of this how
Modi is the relationship of Saudi Arabia
trying to protect their interests with
the oil the second-largest reserves in
the world and then they used Iraq as a
wall as a cushion between themselves and
Iran because Iran and Saudi have
problems they do a lot of proxy wars
between the two of them how much of this
has to do with oil how much of it is
religion how much of it is nuclear how
much of it is power and how much of it
is politics I think honestly it it has a
lot of it to do with politics had a lot
of things to do with with power and also
oil the same time because you have to
know that Iran has been under Sections
recently but they've been doing a lot of
their financing in Iraq behind the table
they've been acquitting a lot of their
products Iran basically uses Iraq as a
as a as a backyard to take care of their
finances meaning what controlling
literally the whole entire Iraqi economy
they under their control but is that
enough for them to survive so not not
enough maybe but but they can they can
use it to to kind of lower the pressure
of the sections on them do you have
Intel yours I mean you're you're big on
Intel obviously you turn we will talk
about your story here but do you have
Intel to know what is Iran's ultimate
motive what is it what are they trying
to do what what are they trying to get
through what is their motivation of
wanting to get closer to Saudi is there
anything there who are they trying to
retaliate to what what is their might
think it's just I do G of the Ayatollah
is to have the Revolution of Iran from
the from the
from the seed of the river they want to
control the whole Middle East and that's
how it been for us meaning the influence
has been going all over Iraq who's been
going to Syria it's gonna go in the Eman
and they want to have control they want
to have a representative of every
country a Lebanon they're everywhere and
I think they want to have that grip of
the whole entire Middle East so I
believe it is more of over power than it
is over everything else you you think
it's more power and control over
everything anything else absolutely so
not religion because a lot of times
people think sunnis and shiaas don't get
along they actually have a lot of things
in common it's just a couple things that
they defer Abu Bakr and Ali it's not a
big difference between the two exactly
so oil you're saying it is a little bit
of oil but it's not a lot of oil nuclear
Iran doesn't have any nuclear they may
do some stuff I know you had some
dealings yourself with uranium that you
you had an issue going on with that so
power and control okay so you get hired
to be a consultant you're in a room with
ten other folks who have Intel
decision-makers who know a lot about
Middle East is there ever gonna be a
time where there will be peace in the
Middle East if yes how if no why yes
will be if we get rid of the Ayatollah
on his government because as you see the
Iranian people they've been protesting
for years trying to get trying to have a
voice but they're being getting killed
just like how the Iraqis we're getting
shot in the head I believe that
everybody been minding their own
business like even the Saudis look the
Saudis had some influence in Iraq in
their own way but not to an extent to
actually cost you harm not to an extent
to control you as a country under their
wing but Iran has been trying to control
Iraq under the wing for the last since
2003 literally so we will have peace if
the Ayatollah goes away because the
Ayatollah is our only goal is to control
the Middle East with his fist is that
possible for that SAP you talk about a
cool revolutional regime collapse that's
that's what you're talking about
yeah is that possible for that to happen
I think it's impossible for the Iranian
people because they don't have so by
themselves because if they don't have
the right
they can never do that as you know back
in 2012 when the Iranians had a protest
and what happened to all the protesters
then when I protested against I met in a
job man mm-hmm they all got booed in
prison because they specialized in how
to put a protest away how to come
protest then how to put a protest away
away the colas yeah yeah and you know
Soleimani was actually the perfect what
is the formula
I think the formula is is to do certain
things that would get your not get your
focus away from what you're trying to
talk about or ask and the reason why
sulemani came to Baghdad because this
was a major issue for the Ayatollah I
think that the Ayatollah does not does
not care less if Sunni Iraqis goes out
protest against him but it terrifies the
Ayatollah if shared Iraqis goes out
protesting protesting has that started
you don't know of course the majority of
the protesters that were not to produce
where she had so that terrified them and
that's why they sent sulemani and Abu
many Mohandas hot eleméry were shooting
people in the head with a sniper with
they used all kind of things against
protesters and the protesters demanded
they would not leave their position so
one on her hand and so Imani has a
established a broom and Baghdad and to
how they can distract the protesters and
the goal was to actually to drag the
Iraqi people and the protesters in a
confrontations with the American people
or but with the American government over
the American military but the protesters
were smart enough because the power of
the internet the power of social media
you have a generation that's completely
educated that is not blind that don't
want just a couple channels like we used
to do in their Saddam in Iran that's
right and they're very open-minded and
they understand politically every single
move Soleimani was initiating in Iraq
perhaps when they attacked the US
Embassy in Iraq the protesters were only
about a mile and a half away but not one
protester entered the Green Zone towards
the US Embassy because they knew that
would be a trap because the goal was to
make a look
the Iraqi people attack the US and but
it wasn't the rack you people these were
the Iranian paid malicious so there are
so many goals to drag Iraq in a
competition in America but people of
Iraq they waking up they don't want any
trouble with America anymore they just
want the Iranian influence to go away
and if that goes the way you think
things will settle down in the Middle
Middle East absolutely in a big way
absolutely so so somebody is watching
this and they are thinking about okay
what would be the method to cool I mean
obviously you know the Iranian
Revolution how it took place in 78 79
the approach they use spreading tapes
and giving tapes to each other
yeah and recording Comenius tapes and
listen to what he's saying this is what
he's saying the shots got all this money
what would be the approach today I think
people have seen everything about diet
Allah the truth is already out there the
approach I think is to to have to
control Iran moves in the Middle East if
we go to negotiation with Iran we need
to make sure Iran does not put its hand
in any other country and if that happens
I think if they leave Iraq alone Iraq
will get someone its own no problem the
only reason we couldn't get up on our
own is because of the ayatollah
government so if they were to do it
today you know i talked to a lot of
family and middle-east and what their
fears are parents specially parents
don't mind with their lives you know
their senators saying I'm 55 years old
whatever but the kids knowing in order
for revolution happen you know what's
gonna happen with students yeah it's
gonna happen with kids younger
generation younger generation it's
always been the case green movement
that's always busy we have in Iraq right
now exactly it's always a younger
movement right so but but for that to
happen it's gonna cost a lot of lives
it's not gonna be they're not gonna do
it and it's gonna be peaceful it's not
gonna be 500 lives it's not gonna be a
thousand life so you know that part yeah
how do you describe that to somebody to
say if you want democracy you got to go
through it or is it part of the recipe
where it's gonna be painful for a period
it's nothing comes for free
I've been telling my fellow Iraqis that
if you think you're gonna get it
peacefully because they've been
protesting peacefully it's not gonna
happen
aren't they have weapons they have
organized militias organized army they
control the leadership of the whole
entire country of Iraq like the
leadership of the Iraqi military as well
right now it's not gonna work unless
blitt is gonna be shed because they're
not gonna live they gonna not gonna
leave peacefully and they haven't tried
the Iranian influence in Iraq have tried
all its cards right now they have ran it
through all of it they call the
protested at Baptist mitches Saddam
Hussein below a co party about this but
you can't call somebody who's a 20 year
old about this who actually was born
right after Saddam had gone away they
don't know what the bath party is so
they've been accusing them with all kind
of names of kind of accusations but they
ran out of it they have accused them
being an agents of the United States
they have accused them of being spies
who believes a dog or the Iranian people
believe in that I don't think the
Iranian people believe in that I think
they really am bill Iranian people are
pretty smart and they know exactly what
the Iraqi people want our problem as
Iraqis is not with the Iranian people
our problem is with the Iranian
government and that's a different our
problem with the ideology of Ayatollah
I think Iran would be a beautiful
country if the Ayatollah wasn't in it
let me ask you a question what you see
82% a support that Sam Soleimani had
when he passed away the Iranian and then
you know well a lot of people are afraid
of voting for the guys similar to what
Trump is that a lot of Trump voters will
never publicly say I'm a trump supporter
you know and then they go vote and they
don't talk about it because the word
about politics within work
how much of Iranians out of their eighty
something million that they have their
country how much of their population
supports ayatollahs philosophy religion
approach of governing the nation I don't
believe the majority of the Iranian
people suppose there's a lot what's
major 60% I believe a lot less than that
that's supported Ayatollah I'm a huge
believer in less than 50% of ordem
absolutely 30% support some have a have
a revolution in Iran you'll find out
only reason I'm asking this question is
because there's a big difference between
50 50 because 50 America right now is
what I say 45 45 and 10
on the panel libertarians which they'll
go you know swing they go this way or
the other way right but you got 45 45
Republican Democrats right yeah do you
think it is a 50/50 split or do you
think it's more 30% that support
Ayatollah and 70 percent cannot wait for
the regime to fall in color I think
saving percent cannot wait for the
regime to okay now wait regime because
look what an example of Saddam Hussein
what did the Saddam Hussein convince the
people that the majority of Iraqis
warned him in power he expected to fight
for six months defending Baghdad and it
took him how long for him to fall down
three weeks because if you tell the
people and convince them that
everybody's support you people can't
express their opinions in Iran you don't
know how soon the Iranians feel I
reached to some of the Iranians inside
of Tehran on social media on asked them
and secretly they would tell me what
they feel but I know when they go to
their social media they're supporting
Cosell Imani they're supporting the
Ayatollah of your run because they're
afraid to and I understand that
methodology because I lived under that
kind of control I lived under Saddam
Hussein and God if you open your mouth
during Saddam Hussein you'll be gone so
I think that and way deep inside of the
Iranian people heart is they don't want
the Ayatollah they want their country
back now let me give you the other
devil's advocate question for you as
well just curious know what you'll say
about this you just said a you know
mistake was made in 2012 when Barack
Obama pulled the troops and the next
thing you know it went from one Saddam
Hussein 200 Saddam Hussein's being in
Iraq and his hands and shambles right
okay Isis came back up etc okay great
now somebody makes okay if there's a
revolution in Iran who is the voice who
replaces it who becomes the new leader
at least at that time there was a
candidate and it was Ho mania jiménez
going to come and he was somebody people
can rally behind for them and against
mosa death with the help of CIA
it was the Shah right people rallied
behind Shah is gonna make you run more
westernized and give women more power
etc etc one don't you need a personality
like that for that to happen like you
need somebody to rally behind yeah who
is that person today I don't think
you're ons got somebody like you know
Iran does not have
but I think that's what the Iranian
people needs to figure out because if
you look at a protest of their if you
look into the protest in Iraq they
figured this out they protest they were
out protesting for about a month or so
and then they figured out we can't just
keep asking for something that we don't
know what we're asking for
we need to appoint a person that we
think is the right leader for this
country who's we
we as Iraqis so Iraqis actually have
found an Iraqi politician that has not
been under the Iranian influence and
this partnership he's actually a Shia
but he is not a religious guy okay he is
more of a kind of he's just like a
liberal mentality he's not under the
Iranian influence perhaps he's been
speaking against the Iranian influence
and he has a very long history of a
speaking against the religious figures
the problem with what ruining Iraq right
now is the religious figures and
politics and I think that the Iranian
people they have a plenty of figures
that are not religious that wants to
help Iran as a country and I think that
if the protesters in Iran figure this
out this could become a possibility but
I don't think the Ayatollah would leave
peacefully that will never happen and we
all know that where would he go if he
did leave like let's just say you know
the Shah leaves
Shah goes here you know he goes to all
these different places where he's
welcome where does the ayatollahs go if
they leave Iran he has nowhere to go
that's the point so that's what I'm
saying is that airight Allah would never
leave peacefully I think that Ayatollah
will fight all the way to the end and I
as I said is they are ready to kill
every single citizen of the Iran or Iraq
or anywhere else before they can leave I
don't think they care I think they
believe in the ideology of the
revolution they believe the ideology
their religious ideology and I think
they love their ideology more than they
love their own people they love the
ideology more than they love their own
absolutely indeed I think that's that's
what well to shame yeah that's what
that's what had been in Iraq there
to shame so so let me ask you so now we
talk about Barack Obama now let's talk
about President Trump in in the past
you've been critical of President Trump
with him putting the would he call it
the Muslim ban and and what that was
like but what are your thoughts about
what he's doing today with the sanctions
he put and what he did in April of 2019
with the IRGC because soleimani was a
part of it and he categorized him as a
terrorist etc terrorist organization
what do you think about the approaches
he and his administration to have taken
less eight and a half months I think
before the election I wasn't really sure
of President Trump after the election he
has a proven to me that everything I
wanted to see to happen is specifically
in Iraq or the rest of the Middle East
specifically is where I am looking at is
everything I wanted to do he did it and
that's the power of asking the right
people talking to military advisors
understanding from people of experience
and I think that's where I gave a
president Trump a five star because he
has a proven to me that everything he
was doing is for a purpose and I think
that President Trump has been going on
the right direction when it comes to the
Middle East and for that I supported him
on the travel ban because there was a
reason why you're supplyin dressed
president Trump officially on the travel
ban cuddly and a recent Ford because we
did have individuals that we battled in
Iraq as a terrorist end up coming inside
of the United States some of them went
to court here and were arrested by the
FBI and there's a reason that we had to
do that because week during Obama's time
we canceled some of the background
checks they were supposed to do and some
of these individuals you have to know
when al Qaeda member run away in Iraq
when there are or when they're put an
arrest against them and they end up
running out of the country they end up
going where they leave Iraq goes to
either Jordan they used to go to Syria
back in the day and from there we
started taking refugees for the UN and
some of them end up coming to this
country that's that's kind of like very
that's very weak you know I think that
we need to put
herself other country here and because
our enemies wants to come here they want
to come inside of this country and some
of them that I have known I've seen
personally I end up making it to the US
and I couldn't believe my eyes
I couldn't believe what I heard when I
found out they were here so I am NOT
against refugees in a way but I wanted
to say but I want to make sure we have a
very strict process we can bring find
good people from the Middle East just
like myself I'm an immigrant myself like
came to this country started all over
again and we need to bring people who
would be a great addition to this
country but I'm against people who would
come to this country and want to harm it
and it will make life for people like
myself extremely difficult so you
support his decisions he made you
support the sanctions he put he keeps
increasing the sanctions on Iran he's
supporting he's telling other UN nations
hey tighten your own restrictions with
Iran don't do business with them these
are all moves being made by somebody who
would like to see an internal regime
collapsing these are this just a formula
if you're looking at a formula on how to
make a cheesecake you put that together
boom yep this is the recipe on how to
create a coup you know people against
the regime you know a revolution is that
kind of the direction you're seeing that
going okay so you're seeing I think he
put a zip tie on the ayatollahs neck and
slowly he is closing that zip tied
tighter and tighter and tighter and as
you can see what's been happening in
Iran in the last 48 hours that's that's
an example to show you that this is the
way to get the Iranian people to make a
move towards the Ayatollah you know
Venezuela I have a lot of people in our
company that are from Venezuela okay and
it came here they love their country
just like Iran ian's love their country
I'm sure there's somewhere inside that
you love Iraq and your family and your
two uncles that were killed by Saddam's
regime I mean listen there's an
emotional connection affinity to the
land that you have exactly but then you
got to do what you got to do you got to
move on and go take yourself you have
kids I have kids you want to have them
be in a safer place Venezuela is got two
regimes you got Maduro and you got got
your right so today Gallo is a voice
that people can get behind and people
can vote
and people can rally behind a figure I I
don't know if an opportunity like this
for Iran's gonna come too often like
what they have right now I mean it's not
like it comes once every three years I
don't think an opportunity like this
with the way the sanctions have been put
because in order for Iran to have the
opportunity for a cool revolution or
regime collapse there has to be
sanctions there has to be pressures the
government has to be tightened they
there has to be a lot of fear from the
top and and us has to create the
sanctions so if another president gets
elected and they remove the sanctions
Iran is gonna start doing business again
around the world with their oil they're
not gonna be afraid they're people right
now but my worries is Venezuela has a
figurehead Iran doesn't have a
figurehead and I would I would certainly
hope if they do want to see something
happen they have to be more urgent than
they've ever been to rally behind a
personality I think the Iranian people
needs to be extremely careful on any
steps they would take right now during
their protest against Ayatollah because
you need to go back in history and
figure out when Moussaoui and
Ahmadinejad were competing against each
other what was the point of that
election what happened to all the
Iranian activists that went on spoke
against the Ayatollah where are they now
prison they're gone yeah because that
was an opportunity to actually figure
out who are the enemy of their Tola
and I think they need to be careful
because this is what Ayatollah did in
Iraq and as we speak just in the last
for 24 hours they have assassinated over
10 Iraqi reporters there in the last 24
hours that's 24 hours as we speak
they're assassinating people right now
in Iraq because their goal is to find
out the activists
the most active voices in these protests
get rid of them and once they're gone
these protests becomes just a loose
cannon and they go away and that's been
the style that I had soul has been using
he did it in Iraq and literally I think
the protesters in Iraq don't realize
this by now but most of their important
figures who started this protest are
going they'll be married and the Iranian
people need to be careful and they need
to be sure who would they appoint as a
that's the part I agree with because you
can't get behind the wrong person you
got to figure out and you cannot move
you you you got to be having meetings
right now figuring out who you're gonna
be done
there's some people in us that would
like to go out there and shop Heloise
you know razor-sharp Alois son there's
been conversations about him wanting to
do it I think it's gonna take a lot of a
lot of people coming together to decide
who they want to do it with let me ask
you who who is Iran scared the most up
in the Middle East of course us they're
not happy about the way trump's are
making the decision putting on the
sanctions well who simply run afraid of
in the Middle East I think there is not
individual that Iran is afraid of in the
Middle East but Iran and the Ayatollah
specifically is afraid of his own [ __ ]
in the Middle East to turn against him
because that's what happened in Iraq and
you have to know that she Iraqis do not
follow the Ayatollah
they follow a Sistani in Iraq they do
not have the same belief as the
Ayatollah perhaps their toll has a point
in himself as the biggest religious
figure for Muslims but we do have a very
small percentage in Iraq there are the
followers of the Ayatollah and they're
the ones that control the rocket
government and the ones that he appoint
to the rest of Iraq so I think that Iran
is afraid of its own believers to turn
against them and that's what I think is
terrifies diet Allah to see Shia
protesting against the Iranian
government I only ask because I wonder
who the people protesting would need
their support to help them that take
place right because not every every
country around the world would like to
see Iran's Empire fall not all of them
there's some that may not want to do
because they'll have control over the
oil you know some nations over there may
help and support more China Russia
depends because it's yes and no but it's
not fully in it'll be interesting to see
who the people can go to have some
backing that gives them courage to go up
against ayatollahs regime it has to be
different than the Iraqi experiment like
in Iraq we do have this individuals who
was part of the rocky government he's
been living in England he's educated
he's fearless person but for Iran I do
not believe it will be somebody from
inside of Iran it has to be an Iranian
who was not inside of Iran
if he's inside in Iran you know that
person will be under so somebody from
the outside has to go into Iran
absolutely absolutely that would be the
perfect way so you know this person is
not part of the lot it's not part of
their intelligence it's not somebody
that you know they haven't played this
game before
the Ayatollah has done this before
that's a lot right now I think his next
move is he will try to appoint somebody
that secretly is under his control and
that's what I'm afraid for for the
Iranian people then you're not doing
anything you're not achieving anything
at that point
so would have to be somebody that the
Ayatollah can not psychologically
control it's a very small window they
got I don't think so big window it's a
very small window together you're so
close
but you know it's it's a very hard
touchdown for the Iranian people I know
but it's possible if they find the right
personality and support that personality
against Ayatollah and I think that it's
possible the shot clock is ticking
though yeah the shot clock is ticking
that's the biggest thing and it's all
about the leadership of the protesters
that's that's why all about the
leadership of the protesters what do you
mean by this it's like they have to have
a leadership they have to have a people
that can actually decide what to do
because if you keep protesting you can
just keep protesting you need a rally
cry you need somebody at the top yes
more people that know exactly where they
can move and that's how the Iraqi
protesters actually been figuring out
things over the last few days so let's
go back to your story so for you you you
were born and raised in Iran right and
you are right now 34 which means you
were born in what year you were 1986
1986 so it take me from the point of
you're 12 years old and you get arrested
what happened there what's your
experience in Iran you know when you
when I was born in Iraq I I grew up in
Iraq really not knowing what what kind
of world I was living in but the older I
was getting in Iraq I was realizing that
there wasn't really much freedom that I
was living under because you watch the
elders being afraid of every single move
they they want to make this was during
Saddam did your Saddam it was a very
well police country but it this way I
mean we have over like 35 different
intelligent agency under Saddam the
police the whole country so people were
afraid to
talk to their own wives about Saddam
people afraid to talk to their own
parents people didn't have a trust in
them on each other completely and people
were afraid so when I when I open my
eyes in Iraq I watched a family that's
being afraid couldn't trust me couldn't
trust each other your own family
absolutely every single family in Iraq
every single family in Iraq we had
brothers that but the brothers away and
they wrote a report to the bath party
what they did is they what's the level
of loyal to do who are you loyal to it
has to be only Saddam because Saddam had
made the rules of that if you don't
report anything that you heard you're
part of it and you'll get executed just
like the other person so some people can
get killed just for the fact they heard
something negative again how do we the
first time you saw that a witness did an
execution I mean I was like around 11
years old because Saddam actually used
to take some of the people they used to
get executed they used to take kids out
of school to witness it what's the
outcome what's the purpose of doing say
how much do you think before you do
anything against the governor
it's a psychological move and it was to
make you think what emotion was it a
producing in you at the as the 11 year
old kid were you I didn't want to watch
death I didn't want it I won't watch it
but most of your teachers are back party
members and they tell you what to do and
if you don't a whole report could be
ridden against you you know they could
end your life could end your family life
so you really didn't have much to say
you had no options other than following
perhaps some of my teachers had a gun
and they're built when they walked to
class because there were bath party
members and what kind of argument would
you have with that teacher none you just
followed and that's what it was until I
kind of got the real taste of it when I
got arrested at age 12 when you're 11
you saw that you went home did you tell
your mom mom this is what I saw today
this what I saw that day or no nothing
was getting discussed at home because I
know my parents would not answer me so
what is your relationship with your mom
and dad at the time like how are you
speaking to them what did the
conversations like just two normal
conversations I'm hungry we know not to
talk about anything politics we know
enough to talk and easy no zero they
would not hear you they will actually
turn around and tell you something that
you know it's fake
so there was no point to talk about it
you couldn't talk about Saddam anywhere
we had an example says their walls have
ears
even the walls even the walls had worked
for Saddam and you can't talk to
anything about it so they taught
everybody essentially to be snitches is
what they did exactly wanted everybody
exactly and reporting reporting was
massive join us at downtown Lake people
writing reports secretly to the bath
party member and the bath parties kind
of put that up to whoever it is and
reports were being written each other we
had family members that reported each
other so it was it was very well policed
country and he wanted it this way this
was his psychological formula who is
this example who did he learn from I
would think you know there's a lot of
controversies that you know Saddam was
an agent of a foreign country that sit
down I think Saddam was not a stupid guy
he was smart he was extremely smart and
intelligent wise the way he looked at
people he was mad you have to know
Saddam worked as the head of the Iraqi
intelligence before he became a deputy
or president in Iraq so many returned
the seventies he had a natural instance
and he established all this formulas to
actually even that even his own family
members if they did something against
him he would know just by the way he
looked at them and that's the kind of
guy Saddam Hussein was just by the way
he looked at them did anybody ever do a
investigation on him to see what
inspired him what did he study what
books did he study who did he follow
which style of leadership millions
admired that and that was there any kind
of stories there that gives insight on
him uh no actually the he was you know
when he was in prison when he was out in
Egypt and he has read a lot of books
he's very he's very well educated even
though like he earned his military rank
in a kind of fast way for being the
president but I think he was very well
educated very well balanced and he is a
very different unique person
psychologically
and I think that's how he controlled
Iraq that's how he controlled every
single person that worked under him even
his own family members were terrified of
him that they didn't know what his next
move would be so he policed this country
in a very unique way where he turned
every single person into informant so 12
years old what happened to when he got
arrested I was walking out of school and
I came out of school and was a common
thing I'm there you know people if you
are not an important figure of society
usually the people who are like in the
bath party or part of the Saddam's
government their kids would have like a
military color Mercedes that will pick
them up with two Republican Guards if
you are not one of these people you'll
be walking home you'll be walking the
ten miles or whatever the miles that you
have to walk to school and it was a
common thing for bath poorni members to
stop you and interrogate you in the
street this was a common thing they can
stop it can talk to you they can take
whatever they have what do you have in
your pocket and you don't have much to
say off to do that so it was a police
officer there were three police officers
that actually approached me and one of
them looked different than the others
and that's the way to actually
distinguish a bad party member something
about them always look different than
average people the way they dress the
way they have their their badges on
their on their chests the way they would
dress is a very different way the way
they would talk you can feel it in the
tone this is someone of a power and when
he approached me asked me if I smoked
because it was a common thing teenagers
smoked in Iraq and if I have any
cigarettes I didn't have anything and I
had money in my pocket and he asked me
is like well do you have any money I can
go get some cigarettes and I said no I
don't have anything I just kept walking
so he put his car in front of me got out
and he came to me and he said turn
around
and started searching me and he found
money that I kept in my pocket and it
was about 250 dinars that I had in my
wallet I had other money that would keep
in my socks knowing this would happen at
any time and I kind of felt at that
point that for me this meant the world
this was like money I put away over
months to buy myself a shoe you know
during the sanctions and
Sadam that things were very difficult
you know I was walking about with a
messed-up shoe and that was open from
the fri couldn't even walk properly and
this was money from holidays and
everything people would give you away
and just kind of put it together to it
to eventually have the price that would
match tours you know to us I used shoe
maybe and when he took it away I felt
like I didn't want to keep my voice shut
anymore so I end up trying to take my
money back and I cursed them and when he
hit me this was a big thing in our
culture when she of course and I curse
them bad and he grabbed me and if it'll
me in the truck and drove me for about
45 minutes and to the Rocky Ministry of
Interior and inside of a prison and what
was it like when you win it it was scary
I went to an area that I never would
Rizzo I mean I they drove for about 45
minutes I still remember the
conversations between the two guards
that was sitting in the back and him and
they said hey he's just a kid he's only
12 why don't you just kick him in the
head and let him go home and he said if
you guys keep talking I'll boot you
where I'm putting him tonight and I
realized at that point I wasn't going
home that night and it came to a
checkpoint which is a place actually I
used to see going by but you're not a
lot to go and send to that place and it
was the Rocky Ministry of Interior and
once I passed the checkpoint and I drove
about it drove about like a mile and a
half this was all the intelligence
headquarters all the scary stuff that
you heard about but you never seen and I
pulled too I got pulled into a slide
door that opened and I went inside and
it was a a prison but I wouldn't say it
look like an American prison it actually
looked like a zoo its cages and I saw
cages like it was just cages and fences
and there was a concrete buildings
behind the cages and i sat there in a
car they took me out and I went to a
room and they gave me a pen and a paper
and they said time and I looked around
all my angles of the room there were
people with bats were in uniform we're
in the exact same uniform as he is most
of them carry the same last name that he
had they were actually from the same
tribe
and when I took the pen it was dark I
was terrified
I took the pen and I signed later on I
found out I sign on a paper stating that
I was an entire government that attacked
a a police officer in a bath party
member to kill him so I was not being
treated as a child I got treated as an
enemy of the state once I signed that
paper and I walked into prison so then
what happened how long were you in there
I was there for about three weeks nine
four week Isis get out my family have
found out so I had actually about 10 or
15 in my socks then I kept and they
didn't find out about the money I went
inside and the prisoners asked me
they're like hey are you fighting with
somebody are you are you helping
somebody like why are you here you're a
kid are there any other kids no just my
was my kid yeah I was I was just walking
into a bunch of prison full of adults
and it's not like an American prison
it's like a war house that's full of
people perhaps they didn't have a place
to sleep everybody kind of slept in a
different mm-hmm because they just kept
people and there was no beds there was
no pillow how many people in the place I
would say about maybe 300 people okay
and there was one bathroom and I was
terrified and one of the prisoners asked
me he said like why did you heat why did
you bother they bring him here I said I
just refused to give my money and they
couldn't believe it what day would they
protective of you prisoners they were
they were actually locusts I had a
prisoner to help me out and I said I am
dying I don't care what happens to me
I'm dying just to let my family know
where I am because then they can do
something or at least just the family to
know I felt at that point my life is
over and I told him that I have some
money in my pocket I hope I've kept in
my socks and I he said you know what
give me the money I gave him the money
he went and called one of the guards at
night after everybody went away and
there was a guard that actually cleaned
the office of the commanding officer in
that prison and there was a landline in
there and you know back then that you
nobody can tell if they use their
landline or not and he told me that
person took money and he could make a
phone call so I they gave that guard the
money
I saw the prisoner hand him the money I
gave him the phone number of our
landline and I was praying that somebody
one of my family members would answer
the phone because they're probably be
looking for me it was late at night and
I didn't come from school and they were
actually looking
all over the place and my brother answer
the phone and asked him please telling
me now who would answer the phone to
know that he called them my brother
answered the phone and he told him that
he's in prison this is where he is and
my family started coming to the prisons
trying to negotiate with the commanding
officer in prison to give him money and
would smash the reports because if the
report doesn't get smashed that was
gonna go to a bigger court and I was
gonna get probably executed and
sometimes government could care less how
old you were once you're considered an
enemy of the state permanent yeah I was
being treated as a fighter now at this
point how what is it what feeling go you
is it producing in you is there hate is
there angrily animosity what do you feel
in I would say I entered that prison a
child I did not leave the same when I
walked away from that prison and when my
you know actually didn't know where they
were taking me when they took me out of
prison I was being tortured of being hit
I came out and I was in a really bad
shape and I thought they were gonna
finish me right there that's what I
thought they took me out to an area I
never been in in three weeks and a slide
door open and I saw my dad and I think
at that point I I I was just in a very
different stage of my life and when I
left that prison I didn't know what was
happening during that time I didn't know
any negotiations between my family or
the commanding officer in prison and
when I left at that place I don't think
my life has ever been the same I left
that place completely carrying hate
against these individuals because I saw
their the violence they carried against
feeling of revenge absolutely absolutely
well your your uncle's already killed at
this point or no they were already dead
yeah so that's already expected yeah and
and the amount of hate that produced
wasn't close to the amount of hate
produce you've been in jail absolutely
oh because I saw like how they treated
you how they treated you like they try
to get confessions out of you you didn't
have and I didn't even know what to say
at that point in my life you know I
didn't even know when to give him and if
they asked for something I would have
gave it to them if they asked me to sign
on a hundred papers I would sign it
just to not give beating and not get hit
and when they hit you they hit you hard
they don't care they treat you as an
animal and that's the people that
controlled you and rolled your country
do you remember any bit till today I
said like do you wake up in the middle
of the night flashbacks or no you don't
have those nights you feel paper
no not flashback to prison but actually
I would say after they have a broken me
I became less afraid of them I was way
less afraid of them leaving that prison
and to this day you know after even I
became a nutter buddies like that though
yes some people you know some people are
gonna walk away they're gonna you know
be a victim but for me I was less afraid
of them yeah when that typically happens
you produce either somebody that
confines and you know kind of a gets
quiet and stays doesn't say anything
because they're afraid but you can also
produce a true believer that never
forgets the way you treated absolutely
and that stays with them it's obviously
that's what happened with you yeah so
now you leave at 17 years old what gave
you the opportunity at that time you're
nine it's 1998 you're 12 years old
saddam is still running iran oh three is
when his regime falls right in 79 -
what's happening during this time
because i know you said in one place
where you said I thought saddam was
gonna live 500 years yeah
religion was never gonna change when it
happened to you do you remember the
moment where you were at when that took
place yeah house in my house house in my
house and I opened my front door there
was an American soldier standing there
and that's what everybody was scared to
make one move towards that American
soldier because they thought that the
Americans will pull out like 99 1991 and
then sit down we'll be coming back to
take revenge many people so people were
very hesitant people couldn't process
the point that Saddam's gone actually
this this tyrant that controlled Iraq
for 35 years is gone it's over people
couldn't believe that fact but when I
opened that door and I saw an American
soldier kind of like I was at a point
where I just wanted to kind of pinch
myself I couldn't believe it
let me ask you a question you said
something I was reading it as well where
you asked the the the soldier that came
to you you guys gonna leave no we're not
gonna leave we gonna stay here is there
a feeling of letdown when the American
troops would come you felt safe and then
they left you felt heartbroken because
of soldier you feel that experience when
they leave your heart broke
I give you my trust I thought you guys
were gonna take care of me but not
America let you down again absolutely I
mean 1991 this is what happened this is
why the thousands of Iraqis died because
they thought Americans were going all
there on to the to Baghdad and then they
pulled out and Saddam came after what he
did to them he bared them alive comical
Ali came over his cousin and buried
everyone a life that didn't fight
against America's so there was a doubt
for the rocky people there was a doubt
that we can't really trust the Americans
if they would really take him out maybe
he'll come back but for me is I got that
assurance from that American soldier
saying are you guys stayin or this is
just another comeback like ninety nine
so he says he's stayin what's your next
move on next move action I opened the
rest of the door we started having a
conversation because if he said no I
would have shut down the door and walked
away but when he said yes I'll bring the
rest of the door and I started ask him a
question and I had about like maybe I
walked with that soldier as he was
moving and I asked him a lot of
questions I asked him all the questions
that I asked that they were not leaving
now at this time do you know a lot have
you been inspired to know your own due
diligence because you knew things but
you couldn't talk about him perhaps I I
learned English but I was never able to
speak it that was the first time I ever
spelled in English does anybody know the
internal rage that is being created in
you during this time oh no did you does
your mom and dad know no no they saying
how mother John just relax you know now
actually was it I kept a very I was so
impressed after leaving prison because
anything would I would do I would die
immediately anybody I would run if I
render the wrong person so my life went
to like a chaos after did you go to
school was a lot of self-education I
went to school and I would I would tell
you I have I went from being an A
student to an F student I couldn't care
anything about but how did you learn
English so when I was studying home
oh so that's what I'm saying you became
a cellphone yeah at home I my dad oh
here's a library cuz the library next to
his books he got from England that when
he was in England now what was he
religion wise what what is your dad my
dad was actually a Shia but he was he
was like an atheist but he didn't tell
anybody he was an atheist but in killing
a man your mom my mom was a Sunni yet
your mom was a senior was a Sydney and
by the way Saddam was a Sunni right even
though medicine yeah he was
even though yeah yeah so okay so then
you're following him you're kind of
asking all these questions etc etc
what's your next move after that because
I know the Iraqi military's getting
started you're the 19th soldier how does
that part take place they made an
announcement in the radio they were
looking for new members to join the new
rocky military after they let go of the
old Iraqi military I felt my freedom was
wasn't gonna come free I wasn't just
gonna sit home and freedom was gonna out
come all the way if I wanted to have a
constitution for the first time in my
life that would have protect my right as
a child somebody has to go out and fight
for it and my generation was just at the
door and I decided I was gonna go join
the new Rocky military because I don't
want to sit home and wait for somebody
to control me again because you know
al-qaeda had entered Iraq that bath
party members started slowly turning
into religious figures from a loyalist
to sit down to more religious figures
because anything against America becomes
automatically a religious movement and I
wanted to go and fight against these
guys equally in an equal battle gun to
gun who are you recruiting was sorry
were you recruiting or no I knew
military was recruiting new the new
Iraqi military was recruiting actually
the American military they were doing
the whole processing the record in that
time how are you viewed in the community
are you voiced you have pull you have
influence now nothing else you're just a
17 year old kid it's quite person you
never heard anything nothing yeah no one
knows what you're thinking about
nobody so it's not like you're playing
soccer outside you got 50 friends you're
the cool guy nothing came from inside of
a dark room in the house to straight to
the racket military got it so 90 rocky
military 19 people 19 soldiers there
where does that relationship go with you
then becoming a sergeant major at 19
years old where the typical sergeant
majors 40 or 50 years old yes and that
responsibility at 19 years old why would
they trust you to be a sergeant major in
2000 you know in 2003 when they
established the first battalion of the
Iraqi military which I was a member of
people were actually encouraged to do
something but once al-qaeda and Islamic
movements realized that they were going
to have people off
in a rocky background fighting side by
American that was more dangerous to them
because we didn't have a digital
database in Iraq you can tell who's who
you couldn't tell anybody we have that
instincts to know what area you come
from where you live in Iraq we can tell
if you're actually where about if you're
a bad party member if you're a
Republican Guard officer we can just
tell by talking to you or what areas you
come from what neighborhood do you live
in because your social status is what
determine who you are so that was a
scary for all these groups to see Iraqis
that would come fight with Americans and
they actually I got in the first
shipment that got sent to karakash which
is actually near the Iranian borders to
be trained by an American company called
NPR I American retired Vietnam veterans
mostly Marines and army veterans and the
second shipment was supposed to make me
the base got blown up by a car bomb and
from that moment everybody was
discouraged to join the rocky military
and in 2004 I went to Haifa Street which
was the most dangerous two miles on a
rockatuer at that time and to retrieve
bodies of a new Iraqi recruits that
actually just came in to fill an
application so that's how much they were
focused on Iraqis joining the fight with
Americans side by my side and in a long
battle I had 29 soldiers I left there
with nine I was shot here in my eye I
had shrapnel above my right eye I had
shrapnel on my knees and once they
started the killing towards Iraqi
soldiers working with Americans the
Iraqi people automatically became
discouraged from that idea because
people have families they will go home
at the end of the day and that's where
they can get you hurt or hurt your
family
so fifty percent of people in my unit in
2004 after that battle quit their job
did they ever come after your family or
no I never went home so when's the last
time you saw your parents so when I won
in 2003 when I left to going into the
party I never went home I never went
home because if I went home I would get
captured they would know I'm gonna I'm
in the military so so maybe it was an
advantage for you for nobody know who
you were except being a quiet nobody
nobody knew anything even in the
military nobody knew because I never
went home truly the ones that were under
the the ginger is the one that had kids
and family and they had to
on leave and that's the dangerous is
that most of the people I was fighting
with the records they came from
Kurdistan so their neighborhoods are
safe some of them were the south of Iraq
they didn't have al-qaeda and have all
these you know like this any makes any
kind of extremists in their areas people
who lived in Baghdad they were the
biggest target some of them would go
home and never come back and you know we
never found what happened to them
so I never went home and I just stayed
in uniform and after that battle I got a
recieved a battlefield promotion I
became a sergeant major in the racket
military and within a week the American
Special Forces requested me to become
the Iraq Amod command sergeant major
because I was the only SEO that spoke
English at that point you were the only
answer that spoken yes at that point at
that point and at what point did you
start providing Intel to the US one day
one day 2005 when I actually got
appointed to the Rocky mid-2005 you
would be how old in 2005 some 19 years
old yes
so at 19-under you're not providing
Intel to to us I became an official
intelligent asset for the US
intelligence and who are you
communicating with you're communicating
with though I know a lot of your
information would go to the White House
President Bush have a lot of your
briefings would be given to him General
Petraeus you know you got you got a lot
of these in the beginning it was
actually strictly to the US military
intelligence strictly to the US military
in the beginning that was like the
beginning when I got recruited is it
because they still don't trust you it's
kind of like no I don't think it was a
it was about a trust it was that I was
just the right candidate in that
building because these were Americans
their job what to build the
infrastructure of the rocket military
they would cross every single day from
an area called the Green Zone which is a
u.s. controlled area to the mo D which
is a next door to the Green Zone
so once the Americans come into this
building this is not considered a US
base 50 about 50 of them but one thing
they didn't realize that the American
government that the terrorist
organization in Iraq started forming
themselves as a political party yeah
people in the government that actually
works with al Qaeda you have people in
the government that works with Iran
you had literally every single one of
your enemies inside of that building but
the Americans did not know how to react
or how to deal with
because this was a new for them I was
basically the only candidate for them
that was a young age never been in the
old government never been in the older a
key military and spoke English and it
was more of the Americanized nco someone
who's trained strictly by the Americans
and I was basically though assurance to
their safety being in the building how
did how did they not know that you're
providing Intel the under Iraqi said the
enemy's side not necessarily on the US
side how were you able to get the Intel
and provided to them without them
knowing that you're the one that's
providing Intel for them because they
did nobody knew what who I had anything
to do with Americans my job was to be
the command sergeant major to provide
security for the building from inside
and outside of the building
how are you one of your meeting with us
to give them the intelligent formation
so in 2005 my my main job was to protect
the intelligent team that was there to
collect Intel inside of the building
later on when I got recruited by the by
the Ogier agents there was nothing I
would not have any communications in
that building with any Americans
howsoever perhaps the Americans were
told not to speak to me if they see me
in the hallway and I would only meet
them in the Green Zone in the secure
location
about six miles from that place nobody
followed you to know where you're going
nobody was there are no new Green Zone
badges I was the only one with the
access to who gave you a Green Zone
Bernanke's but wouldn't that be a
tip-off you know look to to know that
you nobody knew I had that kind of
always nobody knew you had that kind of
access and there was nobody following
you know of course I would know I was I
was trained to make sure that no one
follows me because there are certain
people that had access inside of the
Green Zone but certain places I would go
inside of a US bases in the Green Zone
and areas were where no Iraqi local
nationals would exist now who were some
of the most dangerous people that you
associate yourself with at the time that
were people that could you know cause
create a lot of havoc
back then it was members so we had a
list of all the operators that were
operating inside of the mo D but our
number one and number two of course is
Al Qaeda and the Islamic state
operatives back then which later on
became Isis these individuals are
extremely dangerous they were not just
there to collect intelligence they
actually had the potential to hurt
Americans so the some of the individuals
that I
actually went toe-to-toe with was Subodh
Delaney which is was known to be a
terrorist and the Ambar province which
was actually inside of the building as
well they were killing Americans of
nahuatl province but they got access
through the Rocky Minister of Defense to
be inside of the building and they all
have badges and they try to kidnap
American officer from this out of the
building in 2005 and you're in the
middle of all this stuff yeah I mean at
that age at 19 years old I know I was
dying I accepted it
I had a car bomb blowing up every single
day in my checkpoint I had suicide
bombers blowing up that's just in the
front checkpoint I'm not talking about
the bad people inside I had mortars at
Katusha s falling my chance of me dying
was any day I would come out at 6
o'clock in the morning to the checkpoint
every single day I would have something
that goes on so I was gonna die anyway
it's just customize your own death how
do you want to go down and for me was if
I can cause him as much damage that's
possible I would do so and I think to
this day I believe I was the only
intelligent asset in Iraq that al-qaeda
and all these terrorist organization
could not kill because I was a military
soldier I was protected by my soldiers
that protected by my team's I don't go
to leave home I don't put on uniform
like the rest of the Rockies barracks
every night I sleep in a place where
they think I sleep I sleep somewhere
else where were you sleeping I was
sleeping in a different building than
where my you know building okay yeah got
it yeah so I slept actually an area
where there's nobody what's living there
I would actually enter my room and I
would leave through a window and I'll go
sleep where my other place is because I
couldn't trust anybody in this what's
kind of a life to you about that time do
you have any kind of a personal life
ain't nothing nothing completely no life
no friend no women no girl no family no
no one to talk to nothing once I became
an intelligent asset for the u.s.
intelligence I became a machine for how
long did they left until from 2005 to
2007 you almost have to have no feelings
to be able to do that job it really
there was no feelings about it yeah I
think the joy for it for me personally
it was seeing those guys go down that's
the joy for me I enjoyed every bit of it
I wasn't when did you
know that your purpose you served your
purpose like when was it when you said I
finally got my vengeance was there ever
a feeling like that for you I did fit in
it until today till today you don't have
till today I actually cried when I left
today Modi when they told me that I had
to leave and one of my Intel sources one
of my team members got killed they shot
him in the head it was a message to let
me know that will wait for you forever
until you come out of this building and
I didn't want to leave and the only
reason that my friend died because I
decided to stay oh seven at what point
do you come to the states like how long
he doesn't eat well so you follow and
how did you come here but what was the
US government brought me here yeah yeah
okay and then from there do you have a
courier here what do you how do you make
your money it was their job I came here
in 2008 and I went straight to doing
training on insider threat as you know I
was like the only intelligent asset that
was operating with individual that would
work with you or enemy that would work
with you within the same area so I came
here and I started doing training for
the US military training them on insider
threat training them specifically US
military advisors who are working with
the Iraqi military as a consultant as a
trainer as a cultural adviser as a as a
cult until today I've been doing that
for about ten years and when my book
kind of got released I became a
motivational speaker and I started
becoming more of intrapreneur investing
with myself but I did this out of love
to the military you know they used to
pay me whatever I used to go even if I
didn't get paid I would still go I
thought it was a duty for me to return
the favor that the the United States
have done what's next for year 34 years
old I mean motivational speaking you can
do that but it's not like you know when
you got the kind of life experience that
you got you know sometimes there's a
temptation to want to do something
bigger like what's long-term aspirations
for you next thing for me I will believe
is politics and that's what most of my
fans been asking here or here here
absolutely no aspirations ever to go
back know I'm CEO I'm done you found
your home I can never go back okay even
if a revolution takes place and things
get settle could be you know if that if
the young generation of Iraq win yeah
could be possibility I can go back
visit so I got a question for you I have
the map here okay so obviously when when
most people look at this map you know
it's just kind of like okay it's the
middle east you got sight Arabia Yemen
on you know it got Kuwait Dubai you got
Jordan Israel Lebanon Syria Iraq Iran
how do you look at this when you see
this map what's the first thing you
think about and look at when you see
this map hope one Saltz anybody know
good eye look of neighbors that we
shouldn't have you look at neighbors
that you shouldn't have it just have
never been you know like some of them
has not done but I would say you know
like when you look at Sarah Rabia and
Iran is its two neighbours that never
done you any good these have never done
you any good know why them why Saudi
Arabia what he said cetera
I think Saudi Arabia recently has
changed its politics tours tours Iraq
they have been helpful which I want to
say in the last few years but before
they weren't you know before you know
from 2003 up to 2000 and maybe you know
13 14 it was just as much the same
intention as Iran they were actually
taking care of their business in the
conflict with Iran it in Iraq and it
cost Iraqis a lot of Iraqis their lives
how do you view Israel Israel
I had a plenty of respect for Israel I
think Israel as a small country has
established itself and producing
something good for their own people
they're coming with technologies they're
coming with something that's a great
whenever that Arabs learns to do the
same thing they will do great for their
Nations I don't believe by the way
Israel is behind every problem in the
Middle East as a norm we have in the
Middle East if someone's bathroom door
breaks they will blame Israel for it but
that's been a psychological who's very
government's I know what you say they
will blame my people because they're
used to it they've been soaked in this
idea say all Israel's fault
absolutely I still have people in Iraq
that tell me like oh I think Israel is
behind this and I'm like you'll be crazy
to think that who gets credit for that
mainstream media as it goes back to
media or mainstream yeah
the ayatollahs the people who are
against Israel the enemy of Israel
benefit out of that but I don't believe
that's actually a reality or true Israel
does not have any interests and some of
the things that are happening but their
enemies would like to blame it on them
so you saw World War 3 was trained in
1.5 9 million times it was trending on
Twitter hashtag being used is there any
likelihood of anything crazy taking
place with war coming out of the Middle
East any chances of that taking place
were at least two big war it could if
diet old I get more aggressive I think
of their to light does not pull his
hands out of this those countries or the
Middle East in general I can see that
then I can see that not countries going
against Iran I can see each country
going against its own that's what I see
you can see each country going its own
because in Iraq we're not in Iraq we're
not going against the Iranian people
we're going against the people that are
being appointed our own people they're
being appointed by the Ayatollah so and
that's been the goal is to keep us
divided the only way we can break out of
that is to be united and not care about
what our backgrounds are and just to
look at more Iraqis doesn't matter where
you come from you know if you're easy
disha back if you're a Sunni Shia
Christian whatever you are it doesn't
matter once we learn to look at that we
can break out of the chains dire to love
but on us how often when you in Iraq and
you went to school how often would they
talk about the Strait of Hormuz like was
that a typical conversation or not
really actually we looked at it just in
geography yeah we know that the Gulf we
call it the Gulf yeah I know that URI
nians call it the Persian Gulf Arabs
call it maybe you go you go with the
Gulf
I just call it the Gulf because I really
don't know where the truth is and
sometimes you really have to think you
can go with your emotions when it comes
to what you've been told sometimes you
really have to think Joe graphically who
where does this area belong to but I
think Iran has been using this as a a
pressure point on the rest of the world
and it needs to be a way where this
place needs to be utilized in this place
it needs to be controlled
it's a method of bullion it's a method
leveraged for them it's a method of them
putting the fear because yeah when you
got most of the oil in Asia coming from
here China all those guys are relying on
this yeah they are very worried about
conflict being here because and that
means they're going to be paying the
price because actually China doesn't
have as much oil as they think look what
happened in the UK recently you know
they they easily took a British ship out
of the place that's right and and they
are they use it actually to they use it
to pressure certain countries in Europe
and and in the Middle East - these are
interesting times man I mean I I look at
the people of Iran and they message me
and we talk all the time regularly and
you feel for them because I lived there
for 10 years and I know what it was like
to be a kid and we're going to guess
Saddam so your odds going against Iraq
and Saddam is bombing they're just sold
eight years and yeah I'm living in the
capital we're getting bombed we're going
to City a kadaj pan that palette at the
times rash everywhere you go and bombing
it's it's a lot of fear that it puts in
kids but there's a lot of true believers
that came out of it that are also
looking forward to seeing a revolution
take place to possibly go back and visit
their homeland it will be very very
interesting to see what happens here in
Iran in the next three six twelve months
twelve months yes I think if Iran fixed
itself the rest of the Middle East will
fit will be automatically in peace if
the Iranian people make that change it's
a change for every nation in the Middle
East that's how I feel yeah I think for
that to happen a lot of it has to do
with us depending on who's running the
regime here yeah
switches politics on who they support
they become too much about politics and
when Iran was good with the Shah being
there and there was peace I mean
obviously nothing is perfect tamo Saddam
Hussein had 35 different military
intelligence you know while the Shah had
Saavik but I think if it goes back to
good the people that have been abusing
these nations with oil if they get out
the wind don't do the bullying and the
games I think you can stay peaceful but
if it doesn't there's always gonna be
another Khomeini another Saddam Hussein
to inspire where they're growing up
looking up to these guys and they want
to be the next one I want to be the next
Soleimani it's it's not I don't think
it's gonna be as easy as if Iran is
peace Middle East is gonna be I think
it's gonna be a good 40 60 year of
control before that takes place because
you got to get the generations to have
more peace in them if you don't take
this government you're gonna have maybe
a hundred zayats a lot for the next
decade I agree with you
I agree with you it's not gonna change
it that's why I think you know we expect
things to come peacefully but oh it's
not going to be it's not know it's gonna
be it's gonna be very very ugly and I
think a lot of people typically you know
how well at one time I sat down with a
guy schedu billion Ares families were
3.9 billion dollars and I'm trying to do
business with them and we're sitting out
I'm in insurance I'm coming up on 30
years old he at the time is the son of
this family that's worth 3.9 billion
dollars he sits there with me says
listen Patrick here's the difference
between us and you we know you want us
to do this deal with you we'd love to do
it but for us I wake up every morning
with one job my job is to protect our
families billions your job is to make
billions it's a different situation you
need to take risks we don't have to take
risks I think there's a lot of nations
that don't want to see a lot of movement
here because any kind of risks hurts
them they would much rather be at peace
but these guys the Iranian populace has
to be looking at it as they coming up
with the opportunity for them they're
fighting for their future freedom and
it's gonna take some courage and guts
and risk to be able to make that happen
for them so we gotta learn to take
losses it's inevitable it's easier for
you not to say we're sitting over here
then for them watch and say you don't
know what it's like to be the parent or
the kids and all this other stuff but at
the same time it is what it is look
final thoughts I watch a documentary the
first military intelligence documentary
that was done it was very interesting on
Amazon we'll put the link below and the
book is well we will put the link below
as well I highly recommend you if you
want to know more about what's going on
today and I think it's something for you
to find out for yourself you got to go
study some of these things in in today's
times probably I'd say probably more
than in the last 19 years
eighteen years since 9/11 happened I
think that's probably more important
today to study the conflicts taking
place in Middle East today then probably
the last 10 or 15 years so if you
haven't read this book yet we'll put the
link below for you to go purchase the
book the documentary Mario let's put the
link below as well having said that how
Modi thank you so much for coming out
and sharing your Intel with the rest of
us and some of the information
experiences with the rest of us my
pleasure it's an honor to be here it's
been it's been a blast if you like to
sit down with Hamady just some regarding
the Middle East you will definitely love
these other two videos one of them is a
video I made on the history of u.s. Iran
especially with the conflicts taking
place today recently after the soleimani
killing and then the other one is an
energy I do a general Spalding who had
some experience in China that is
probably very important for everybody
around the world to know about because
he specialized in 5g and how China is
trying to be the largest empire in the
world so if you want to watch the Iran
1-click if you want to watch a China one
click here and if you haven't subscribed
to the channel yet click here thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
you